hey guys it is februari februari it's
it's the second I'm Jessa mrs. games for
news first up the Ghost Recon wildlands
closed beta is now available for pre
load on pc xbox one and ps4 we can
confirm that the ps4 file size is about
21 and a half gig and the beta runs from
februari 32 februari 6 the wildlands
beta will have you exploring the region
of it takua in a near future Bolivia
where the Santa Blanca drug cartel is in
control all of the content can be played
solo or with up to three friends in coop
for a chance to get stuck in yourself
sign up on the wildlands website which
you can find in a link in our story on
gamespot next up the dev kit menus from
the Nintendo switch have leaked as a
result of nintendo nintendo portugal
accidentally posted an unfinished
nintendo switch commercial to youtube
and without the switch games playing on
the console the frequent shots back to
the screen are actually hilarious the
now removed video shows the application
device and firmware settings on the
switch screen as well as the fact dev
kits feature 64 gigabytes of internal
storage double that of the 32 gigabytes
in the retail version one screen has a
reference to an unknown application
called tandem the device menu shows the
ability to manually and automatically
set the time toggle auto brightness and
make changes to the console sleep mode
in other switch news nintendo president
tatsumi kumashima has acknowledged that
some people see the slate of launch
titles as weak but responded our
thinking in arranging the 2017 software
lineup is that it is important to
continue to provide new titles regularly
without long gaps this encourages
consumers to continue actively playing
the system maintains buzz and spurs
continued sales momentum for nintendo
switch as games industry derbez points
out nintendo offered similar reasoning
for the launch of the way you back in
2012 but several intended launch window
games such as Pikmin 3 and the wonderful
101 were delayed finally 500 million
has been awarded in favor of ZeniMax in
their lawsuit against oculus over the
rift gonna max the parent company of the
Third's to softworks alleged that
virtual reality technology it owns was
stolen and used to develop the oculus
rift it had been seeking 2 billion in
damages and 4 billion in punitive
damages the jury found oculus label of
copyright and trademark infringement as
well as having breached a zani max
non-disclosure agreement oculus parent
company Facebook was found not liable a
key issue in the case was whether work
done by John Carmack who formerly worked
at ZeniMax having owned subsidiary its
software enabled the creation of the
oculus rift while at ed ZeniMax have
insinuated they may seek to inhibit or
block sales of the oculus rift saying we
will consider what further steps we need
to take to ensure there will be no
ongoing use of our misappropriated
technology Carmack has since spoken out
on Facebook explaining I never tried to
hide or wipe any evidence and all of my
data is accounted for contrary to some
stories being spread being sued sucks
for the most part the process went as I
expected there is a heck of a lot more
to the back and forth here so for the
full statements from cinemax and karmic
check out a stories on gamespot that is
everything I've got for you today do
leave me your thoughts on today's
stories in that comment section head to
gamespot for news on the Last Guardian
and I will see you tomorrow